we had a beautiful display at the market
each week pretty say we had a lot more
than we could eat and we said gosh we
gotta do something with this so we we
really thought we had it made
Anita and Jim McKeen er retirees who
moved from Houston to the Texas
countryside in 2013 their plan was to
live well and grow food on a 10 acre
homestead earning extra money selling
produce at the local farmers market we
did amazingly well
they grew beets okra carrots kale and
Swiss chard soil out there's very sandy
and the beets just grew like man now the
obvious thing to do when you got more
beets than you can sell is to make
pickled beets and can live like most
states however Texas has a so called
cottage food law that exempts certain
items sold at farmer's markets from the
state's commercial food manufacturing
regulations foods like bread produce
nuts jams popcorn and of course pickles
but what constitutes a pickle and who
gets to decide the mckameys discovered
that the Texas Department of State
Health Services takes the narrow view
what are pickles pickles are made from
cucumbers that have been preserved in
vinegar brine or a similar solution only
pickled cucumbers are allowed under the
cottage food law legislature didn't say
that the Health Department in all other
pickled vegetables are prohibited so in
order to sell their pickled beets at the
farmers market the mckameys needed a
commercial food manufacturers license to
build a commercial kitchen to submit the
recipes to a government contractor at
Texas A&M University and to register for
a $700 food manufacturing class and it's
only once a year so if you miss this
October man it's a whole year before you
get another shot at it
we we got right down to signing up for
the class I was gonna take it despite
the fact people said you won't learn the
damn thing in there
and then saw that $700 since if you know
this is crazy
this is insanity preposterous the
mckameys neighbor Virginia Cox also
grows and sells food at the local
farmers market she'd like to be able to
pickle her leftover okra I could make a
whole lot more because it doesn't sell
this week I can take it back to the
market next week if it's fresh and it
doesn't sell this week it's not going to
sell next week today
the mckameys farm lies fallow but they
have decided to take the state of Texas
to court with the help of the Dallas law
firm Drinker Biddle and reap who took on
the case pro bono their main argument is
that the regulations on cottage food
production are unreasonable and stifled
their economic opportunities people
can't afford that kind of stuff that
shuts them out as precedent the mckameys
case invokes that landmark 2015 decision
by justice Don Willett striking down
occupational licensing for Texas eyebrow
writers they're challenging the health
department's definition of pickles and
subsequent regulation on the grounds
that it impinges on their
constitutionally protected right to earn
an honest living the Texas Department of
State Health Services wouldn't comment
on the pending lawsuit but defended the
agency's rule as reflecting the most
common interpretation of the word pickle
it forces you if you want to do a pickle
be to go to a $700 a class that has
actually nothing to do with with home
canning and now we've got hundreds and
hundreds of of occupations that you got
to pay the government to do your job for
now the case is still pending and it's
just entered the discovery phase but the
McKay knees are optimistic about its
outcome you know we talked about
pickling beets but it's a lot lot bigger
issue it's about economic freedom
and and government by bureaucrat
regulations that got nothing
well it's who bought and paid for the
bureaucrat